nous voulons vraiment organiser des jeux
généreux accueillants ouverts sur le
monde des jeux de passion et des jeux de
sens un projet câline célébration
extraordinaire et un héritage de long
terme pour le plus grand nombre c'est un
projet pour tous il y a 6 ans Paris
était désigné ville haute pour les Jeux
olympiques d'été 2024 aujourd'hui à un
an de l'événement mondial le budget
annoncé ne fait qu'augmenter en cause
l'inflation le coût des transports est
aussi celui de la sécurité alors la vie
de Paris va-t-elle pouvoir tenir son
budget qui paiera la facture en cas de
surcoût
les JO de Paris étaient censés être
sobre et économique en 2017 Paris
annonçait un budget de 6,6 milliards
d'euros aujourd'hui entre le kojob et la
solideo le coût total s'affiche à 8,8
milliards d'euros et a tout simplement
le sujet de l'inflation de l'euro 2017
l'euro 2023 n'est pas le même et
l'inflation sur les coûts notamment les
coûts énergétiques certes mais d'une
façon générale il ne sera pas comme
certains jeux qui ont été multipliés par
trois par deux par trois voire 4 alors
si le montant des 8,8 milliards d'euros
est tenu ce sera en effet des Olympiades
sobre par rapport aux éditions
précédentes c'était plus 12 milliards
les 15 et 36 milliards Tokyo c'était 21
milliards là on avait promis 6 on est à
8 peut-être qu'on va passer à note
peut-être qu'on va passer à 10 si le
budget de ces jeux est particulièrement
bas c'est surtout du fait des
infrastructures qui existent déjà à
Paris seul que construction sont à
prévoir pour l'événement et elles seront
encore utiles après les JO il s'agit
donc plutôt d'un investissement sur le
long terme mais là même si il va pas élu
et jupe de toute façon il y aurait eu
cette construction on va construire une
piscine dans le 93 dans tous les cas il
y a une piscine parce que c'est
l'endroit où sable moins bien agile et
les enfants en 6e culturelle sont
réutilisables pérennisé en réhabiliter
pendant 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans 50 ans on
voit un siècle mais encore aujourd'hui
des infrastructures qui a été construite
pour les Jeux Olympiques de Paris hier
soir l'addition devrait tout de même
continuer d'augmenter le montant de 8,8
milliards d'euros n'intègre pas les
coûts liés à la sécurité pour les JO de
Londres en 2012 la sécurité avait coûté
1,16 milliards d'euros en 2017 dans le
dossier prévisionnel pour Paris 2024 250
millions d'euros ont été budgétisés à
cet effet
encore le budgeto Jeanne pour la CN
d'ouverture on estime qu'il va coûter
beaucoup d'argent
de sécurité d'organisation très
importante sur une cérémonie qui sera
assiette ouverte ou la Seine en dehors
d'un stade oui ça va coûter l'argent
s'ajoute à cela le fiasco de la finale
de la Ligue des champions au Stade de
France en mai 2022 qui inquiète les
organisateurs et là il peut y avoir
aussi des actes de malveillance pure ou
de terrorisme et c'est ça que le monde
du sport en général elle craint parce
que quel entre guillemets plus belle
fenêtre d'exposition médiatique pour des
pour des pour une malentent pour des
pour des revendications
extrémistes que un événement qui va être
retransmis dans le monde entier qui va
toucher
1 2 3 milliards de gens alors présenter
un budget de 6 milliards d'euros
était-il raisonnable lors de la
candidature de Paris 2024 la critique
trop ambitieux et qu'on est plus
imaginer faire un événement type Jeux
Olympiques qui est quand même rappeler
le plus grand événement sportif au monde
et le plus important qui a un coût moyen
supérieur à 15 milliards on a été trop
ambitieux à imaginer ainsi soit c'est
bien on aurait pu présenter à un budget
plus comment dirais-je plus on
adéquation ce qui se passait par le
passé alors qui va régler la note de ces
jeux parisiens déjà il faut comprendre
que le budget initial est financé à 96%
par des recettes privées avec la
billetterie les partenariats la dotation
etc par contre tout dépassement sera
pris en charge par l'État et donc par
nous le Parlement a voté lors du projet
de loi de finance 2022 une garantie de 3
milliards d'euros au kojob donc si le
coût total reste en dessous des 10
milliards d'euros le kojob pourra
utiliser librement cet argent en
revanche s'il passe au dessus des 10
milliards il faudra trouver d'autres
moyens
76 ils ont ils ont dépassé le budget
nous fixer une taxe sur le tabac les
fumeurs payés la taxe olympique
Athènes une dette aussi les souscrit une
tête il lui a fait beaucoup de mal
ensuite après la crise de ce point donc
hier soir le vin d'impôts soit
souscription une dette si on dépasse on
est à un angle échéance évidemment on
échéance on est aux alentours de 8
milliards
sur le coût total
je serai assez étonné
ou n'augmente la facture de 1,8
milliards en moins de 18 mois d'ici août
[Musique]